Ron DeSantis for a while has been
wearing it's it's I it's it's I laugh
because it's crazy that this is where we
are in American politics DeSantis has
been wearing high-heeled cowboy boots
for a while but now there is a new
suspicion that he's also wearing lifts
inside the boot which by the way Trump
is also suspected of wearing don't think
the sanctimonious is the only guy doing
this so uh Ron DeSantis officially is
only five nine
um but there are images of him looking
as tall as people who are known to be
over six feet tall so of course the idea
would be DeSantis puts a lift inside the
boot and then wears a high heel and then
he looks 6-1 and people think he's
taller than he actually is all of this
stuff really matters
tall candidates tend to do better now do
they tend to do better because they're
tall well that's a different question